so we've been experiencing somewhat of a
controversy around the David Pakman show
taking live calls for a long time we
didn't take live calls at all because we
didn't have the technology for it we
ultimately obtained the technology to
take live calls in a way where people
could get in a call queue and we could
bring people on one after the other and
it's a pretty controversial segment on
the show a lot of people love live calls
others hate life calls I've had people
cancel memberships because they hate
live calls so much
I've had people join because they think
it's so great that we hear from the
audience via the live calls segment so
this has been a pretty major rift among
the audience and then of course a lot of
people said live calls I've never heard
those and that's the case with any one
segment which is not everybody is aware
of every single segment that we do so
lately the live calls have definitely
been better I think there's a couple
things that we're doing number one in
both the video that publishes on YouTube
that says we're about to take calls and
now when you call the number
it also says this we have messages to
people saying have your question ready
and ideally written down no speakerphone
be at your phone listen for your area
code be prepared to get right into your
question that has improved the calls to
some degree I think that I have smoothed
out some ways of interrupting the
callers that filibuster and give me five
minutes of background and it's not even
clear they have a question and if they
do by the time they're done with their
five minutes they often have forgotten
it I I think I'm being a little better
about Inter interjecting there and not
letting that become a disaster yeah
there definitely has been an improvement
overall but we still get those rambling
preludes we still get people who want to
ask six or seven questions sure it can
only get to one but yeah I think we're
headed in the right direction I think we
are but we still decided to put it up to
an audience vote we initially had sort
of an informal survey done of the
audience and then we said listen you're
gonna you you can vote via patreon where
if you make any contribution ending in
0.01 like a dollar oh one two oh one
whatever that's about for live calls if
you make any contribution ending in
point oh two so like if you donate a
dollar and two cents or three dollars
and two cents that's a signal
you are against live calls and what I am
here to announce to you today is that we
are going to be keeping live calls but
we've also considered people's comments
about limiting them so people more
people want the live calls to remain
than the number of people who want live
calls to go but we've heard the people
that say you should not do a ton of live
calls every single week so there's a few
ways we can do that one thing is we keep
it to only once a week and it's all only
on the Friday show right so if you want
to avoid that you can easily avoid that
another possibility right and this is
something we could think about we'd have
to think about the logistics is that we
take like just six minutes of live calls
every single day so instead of a
voicemail at the end of the show we take
out the voicemail and we take out one
story and we combine that and we can do
like three two-minute live calls or
something like that
the upside is people will get more
stories on the Friday show maybe they
like that
the downside is if you don't like live
calls there would be a little bit of
live calls every day so I'm open to
changing that right now the plan is we
will continue with live calls on Friday
sort of overlapping or alternating that
with a classic interview which people do
some seem to like unless they hate it
and skip over it which some people do
and we've heard we've heard the voice of
the audience which is keep the calls one
but consider limiting them improving
them and condensing them within sections
of the program yeah I mean doing the
live calls every day would kind of be in
keeping with other talk shows because
there are many other talk shows that do
that right we just don't know if that's
the right fit for our show and for now
we'll probably just limit it to the once
a week thing yeah I think that for now
that's that's how it's going to stay but
I am open I'm at your service okay this
seems to be the simplest thing just do
what we're doing keep them within a
segment or two just on the Friday show
if people like the live calls they're
very easy to find if people don't like
the live calls it's very easy to skip
them but this is something that you can
send suggestions and ask me questions
about on Instagram the show is now on
Instagram at David Pakman
and earlier this week we did a ask me
whatever you want
segments on Instagram where people could
type in their questions and then I would
type a response and then it would
publish it and a lot of questions and
suggestions there about formatting
issues related to the show so if you're
not following the show on Instagram yet
a David Pakman show
please do it and because it's one of our
newer platforms you have more direct if
you ask a question on Instagram because
it's new it's almost guaranteed it's
gonna be answered versus live calls
where we have 12 to 15 people holding by
the time we're done because it's become
so popular if you want a direct line to
the show right now Instagram is it until
of course it fills up with Pats fans and
stuff like that and then we would you
know have a harder time getting to
everybody's questions I used to reach
out to you directly or so I thought
directly by YouTube comments or and I
learned quickly enough that that was not
the best way to do it right you realized
you were moderating the comments you
were leaving and that they weren't
actually getting to me in many in many
ways and then you know Pat his brain
almost exploded when he came to that
realization